[Música]
después del ataque en belgorod que Rusia
atribuyó a Ucrania se reivindicaron las
milicias que se hacen Llamar cuerpo de
voluntarios rusos y legión de Rusia
libre hay confusión sobre los episodios
en la frontera entre los países en
conflicto Quiénes son los integrantes de
estas milicias Y qué principios siguen
para el análisis vamos a conectar con
Lucas Martínez analista de inteligencia
Y seguridad autor de los libros visión
global y terror global Muchísimas
gracias Lucas por estar en directo a
américa qué tal Buenos días mire
Comencemos por el principio Quiénes son
estos grupos los russian voluntad
como se dice en inglés cuáles son sus
orígenes y cuáles son sus objetivos
Bueno realmente el origen de estos
grupos no está muy claro como bien ha
comentado usted es algo difuso
seguramente está integrados por
ucranianos de origen ruso o rusos que
están descontentos con el régimen de
Putin pero sobre todo esta incursión
está llevada a cabo
auspiciada y facilitada por fuerzas
ucranianas en su gran mayoría de hecho
cuando se dieron imágenes ya se
advertían que el personal que estaba
formando parte de estas unidades era
personal que sabía que estaba adiestrado
bien adiestrado y muy bien equipado
entonces es una especie de pequeño grupo
creado al efecto al estilo de como vimos
en su día la invasión de Ucrania perdón
de crimea en 2014 esos pequeños
sometidos verdes que nadie sabía a qué
parte o no llevaban distintivo de ningún
país pues esto podríamos decir que es
algo equivalente Pero esta vez lo está
sufriendo Rusia pues estamos en un
momento de la guerra en la que las
partes necesitan desesperadamente
proclamar alguna Victoria y en ese ánimo
Rusia ha dicho que por ejemplo Ucrania
recurre a este tipo de tácticas con
estos grupos milicianos para desviar la
atención por ejemplo de su derrota en
bajmudo o para intentar movilizar a las
tropas rusas lejos del frente Usted qué
opina
bueno en parte ambos razonamientos son
ciertos y me explico un poco
badmud si bien es cierto que no tenía ya
un valor táctico ni estratégico real era
más un tema simbólico para ambos
contendientes el haberlo perdido o el
que Rusia haya ocupado lo que es el
núcleo urbano ha sido doloroso para
Ucrania evidentemente y esta operación
llevada a cabo justo Un día después o
dos días después de que esto sucediera y
de que estuviera en todos los medios el
tema de basmud ha hecho que se cambie
totalmente el foco y se ponga el foco en
este asunto con lo cual nos ha vuelto a
hablar de bambú en dos días un evento no
estamos comentando aquí entonces creo
que por un lado ese era el objetivo o
parte de los objetivos de esta incursión
Claro porque usted cree que era creíble
pensar que una incursión de este tipo
iba a tener éxito en términos de tomas
de territorio por ejemplo cuando estaban
entrando precisamente hacia Rusia y y
dicho esto qué tan activos cree usted
que son estos grupos antiputín Más allá
de la frontera con Ucrania
como bien dice Más allá de la frontera
con Ucrania no son muy activos De hecho
no hay gran oposición Y hasta ahora no
han actuado en Casos puntuales o en
algún lugar puntual Pero lo que sí es
cierto es que esta operación también
cumple la finalidad de crear
incertidumbre en el bando ruso porque
realmente el que se ha atacado a la
frontera
directamente de Rusia con Ucrania está
duplicando los kilómetros de frontera a
cubrir por parte de Rusia y el éxito
tampoco hay que esperar grandes
operaciones militares porque no tiene
fuerza Ucrania para entrar en Rusia y
ocupar un terreno permanentemente pero
una incursión como esta de 24 horas o 48
en el cual de inclusión de helicóptero
capturan dos o tres vehículos y crean
este pequeño caos pues imagínense si
esto comienza en hacerlo día sí día
también en pequeños puntos pues la
incertidumbre y la necesidad de Rusia de
cubrir esa frontera se multiplica con lo
cual consigue tener un objetivo bastante
interesante pues mire de acuerdo a lo
que usted me dice ya no sería creíble
pensar que Ucrania como ha dicho no tuvo
nada que ver con esta dentro del
territorio Ruso y además hay medios de
comunicación que informan que de hecho
estos grupos operan bajo el ala de la
inteligencia ucraniana esto lo han
reportado múltiples agencias y aquí le
pregunto cómo sería esa relación entre
estos grupos o su papel en medio de la
guerra porque el Washington los ha
relacionado con ideas neonazis con una
ideología de extrema derecha Cuál es
Cuáles serían entonces sus sus papeles
Dentro de este conflicto Bueno creo que
como suele ser En estos casos la
respuesta más simple es la más acertada
o la más cercana a la verdad no son
grupos compuestos por en parte por
fuerzas ucranianas fuerzas regulares o
fuerzas de parte de la fuerza de defensa
de Ucrania no dudo que haya voluntarios
también que sean que han avistado estos
grupos
y evidentemente esto está dirigido y
orquestado desde el Estado Mayor de
descenso ucraniano tiene todo el sentido
como he dicho antes obliga a Rusia a
cubrir más kilómetros de frontera ha de
traer fuerzas Crea una sensación de
intranquilidad y de vulnerabilidad en
parte de la población rusa y además en
cada incursión pues pueden tener un
cierto éxito capturando vehículos
destruyendo algún vehículo derribando
algún avión Por lo cual Es evidente que
es una maniobra más de la fuerza
ucranianas totalmente legítima Por
cierto mire el jefe del grupo
hace declaraciones que son incendiarias
y que atacan incluso al gobierno ruso de
Vladimir Putin en unos de sus últimas
declaraciones pregoni dijo que estos
ataques o esta incursión mostrarían que
Rusia podría cambiar el carácter de su
llamada operación especial en Ucrania
para convertirla o denominar la
propiamente en una guerra Usted cree que
puede haber algún cambio en los términos
de la guerra a partir de esto
fíjense que creo que ese precisamente un
paso que Vladimir Putin debería en
teoría tal como ha ido se ha
desarrollado la guerra debería haber
dado si realmente quisiera movilizar a
todos sus ejércitos pero que aún se
atreve a darlo por la consecuencias
sociales internas que puede tener hay
que recordar que si se declara estado de
guerra Entonces ya es cuando tendría
manos libres para desplazar la zona de
combates a soldados de reemplazo cosa
que ahora mismo no puede hacer entonces
creo que dar ese paso sería admitir de
cara toda su población que las cosas van
francamente mal sabemos que el control
de la información dentro de Rusia es muy
importante pero se va a emitir de Cara a
su población que la cosa va mal y por
otro lado empezarían A ver llegar
cadáveres resultados de reemplazo Y eso
sí que podría tener un impacto bastante
negativo para el gobierno de Vladimir
Putin bueno Y finalmente quisiera
preguntarle si estas incursiones
tendrían algo que ver con la tan
esperada contraofensivo ucraniana
en parte podríamos suponer que sí porque
como digo antes Esto está obligando a
Rusia a pensar dónde puede ser el
siguiente golpe y a desplazar fuerzas
para cubrir la fronteras no obstante es
una frontera inmensa creo que recordar
que son entre 800 y 1.000 kilómetros por
lo tanto cubrir todo eso es imposible
siempre va a haber posibilidad de que
alguien la cruce y acaba este tipo de
acciones Pero evidentemente va a obligar
a Rusia a replantear su despliegue y
tener unidades preparadas para
reaccionar en caso de que ocurra Algo
similar en otro punto bien pues ese
Lucas Martín analista de inteligencia Y
seguridad a ustedes de muchísimas
gracias y que tenga un feliz día Muchas
gracias Igualmente Pero en cambio
nuestros televidentes les pido quedense
con nosotros hacemos una pequeña pausa y
ya regresamos